it's checking some work but I finally
have them the worst of the worst where
let's just say I put them in a hole two
away the hole whose rumors Meno that
some of them have abilities oh yeah I
have seen things maybe Superman was some
kind of beacon for them to creep back
from the shadows
want to assemble a task force of the
most dangerous people on the planet who
I think can do some good
they're bad guys exactly and if anything
goes wrong we blame them we have
built-in deniability what makes you
think you can control because getting
people to act against their own
self-interest is what I do follow him
[Music]
well they say about the crazy ones huh
I'm just gonna hurt you really really
hey youtubers it's Charlie so Warner
Brothers decided to release the Suicide
Squad footage officially so now we can
do an actual breakdown so let's go
really like the thing everyone's talking
about in this trailer is Jared Leto's
Joker and the origin story for Harley
Quinn that looks like what's going on at
the end of the trailer where he's
torturing her really what the footage
tells us is that this is going to be an
origin story for the Suicide Squad the
first origin story but in this universe
like this takes place in the continuity
of Batman V Superman so this is way
after death in the family the Joker has
already killed the Tim Drake Robin and
were like way past that
so when Ben Affleck is in this movie it
will take place in the continuity after
Batman V Superman so expect his suit to
look different that's why he looks a
little bit different in the trailer the
suit that he's wearing in Batman V
Superman is the one that he hung up 20
years ago and yes Jared Leto's Joker
will spill over into the other like you
know Batman V Superman Justice League
movies in some way unless something
really crazy happens or like the movie
bombs he will be the Joker indefinitely
but yeah this movie's gonna make a ton
of money no matter what on top of that
Suicide Squad is going to be a franchise
itself so expect like Suicide Squad - a
couple years after this movie comes out
really what I want to talk about is all
the supporting characters like Cara
Delevingne is enchantress I feel like
that's what's gonna make or break the
movie the movie isn't gonna be built
like solely on Harley Quinn and the
Joker originally Tom Hardy was supposed
to play rick flagg he had to drop out
because of a scheduling conflict so I
think they changed the narrative of the
film a little bit to focus more on Will
Smith's character just because he's like
the biggest actor inside the Suicide
Squad right now so just expect him to
get proportionately more story in the
movie than the other characters it's a
big leads in this movie Jared Leto Will
Smith and then collectively the Suicide
Squad as a teen together
Batman is a very small part of it the
best example that I can give you of this
movie you just in terms of story in the
way it's gonna feel the way it's gonna
flow is David Ayer Savatage done with
better actors that's really like a bad
example to give because I didn't like
that movie at all but you Thea it's a
bunch of misfits somebody inside the
group is probably going to betray them
at a certain point you see how the
narrative kind of feels a little bit
similar to sabotage there will be no
Suicide Squad story where one of the
members of the group won't go rogue the
twist is always that it's not the
character that you expect like Harley
Quinn will probably hate the [ __ ] out of
the Joker in this movie even though it
seems like she has a total boner for him
remember these are all villains but
they're not the bad people in the movie
the most evil people will be Amanda
Waller and the Joker the whole point of
the Suicide Squad is for you to
sympathize with them even though they're
really bad let's look at the slow motion
of them all together so right right now
like my favorite supporting characters
you know just looking them visually
because they don't have a lot of lines
that I'm most excited about or
enchantress I'm a big Cara Delevingne
fan killer croc king shark and katana
now you also to remember that Hugo
Strange is in this movie too like he'll
appear like in all these scenes where
Harley Quinn is basically behind bars
like before she puts the makeup on this
looks like it happens after this Joker
torture scene I'm guessing that that's
gonna be in a flashback I don't think
she's going to become Harley Quinn in
present day like she'll have been Harley
Quinn for a while it's like that shot in
Batman V Superman where Ben Affleck is
looking at the graffiti Batman suit like
the one that the Joker marked up after
he killed Robin but like I said Suicide
Squad big team so don't expect
everyone's flashback like origin stories
to be as big as the others like Will
Smith probably gonna get a big one
Harley Quinn and the Joker gonna get a
huge one rick flagg what you know I mean
Willy Joel Kinnaman is the new Rick
Flagg so because it's not Tom Hardy yet
we'll see you I'm wondering how much
they changed the character but I know a
lot of you are asking about Suicide
Squad comics and stories to read I've
already done a video about that where I
make some recommendations so I'll put a
link in the description just to talk
about the story a little bit it's
probably gonna be fairly simple like
when you have this many characters the
story needs to remain relatively simple
in order for the movie to not fall apart
I'm just expecting that they included a
lot of Easter eggs from the comics and
that they didn't adapt like straight-up
adapt a comic book story Zack Snyder
said like they they just made up the
story for Batman V Superman in a room by
themselves like it had nothing to do
with the comic so I think it's the same
deal with Suicide Squad really I think
the biggest thing that this movie has to
do is sell this guy here self Jared
Leto's Joker performance which is
probably why he didn't come to comic-con
they didn't even intend to release this
trailer like they weren't gonna do it
until it leaked so they probably weren't
really going to start marketing this
film til we got closer to Batman V
Superman like they're probably in a
dovetail with that just like if like a
billion people go to see that movie they
want them to
see a trailer for Suicide Squad - I
don't want to give like a big thumbs-up
or a thumbs-down - Jared Leto's Joker
yet just because he's barely in this but
let me don't you guys think you know
just based on this footage and you know
even if you haven't read Suicide Squad
comics before like what do you think
about this I think it's gonna be really
weird especially for people that have
seen all the Christopher Nolan and
unlike all the the Michael Keaton all
the previous Batman films but I do think
it'll be fun okay so a whole bunch of
trailers stuff coming in the next couple
of days I'm trying to get through
everything I was gonna do a Deadpool
video Nick so I'll probably just do that
next and then I'll do arrow season 4 so
there's a bunch of stuff to talk about
in case you haven't seen it you can
click here for my flash season 2 trailer
breakdown and you can click here for my
Batman V Superman trailer breakdown so
lots of great footage just watch it like
10 times in a row in a loop so thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you